so we're asked does the mean value
theorem apply to H over the interval and
they actually give us four different
intervals here so we should separately
consider them and this is the graph of y
is equal to H of X so pause this video
and see does the mean value theorem
apply to H over any or all or some of
these intervals all right now let's work
through this together and in other
videos if the if the words mean value
theorem are completely unfamiliar to you
I encourage you to look at the mean
value theorem introduction or the
existence theorem introductions on Khan
Academy but as a review for those of you
who are familiar with the mean value
theorem the conditions are if we're
dealing with some closed interval from A
to B we have to be differentiable
all right just diff actually just write
it out differentiable over the open
interval from A to B and we have to be
continuous over the closed interval from
A to B or another way to think about if
you're differentiable you're definitely
going to be continuous so this second
condition condition the condition just
make sure that we're continuous at the
endpoints of our closed interval but if
these conditions are met then the mean
value theorem tells us and I'll just
visually draw it because this is a
review here so let's say that this is
our function so let's say our function
looks like this this is a and this is B
and let's say that we meet these
conditions over this interval the mean
value theorem tells us that there's
going to be some value let's call it C
in the interval where the derivative of
C is equal to the average rate of change
from A to B so the slope of the secant
line is the average rate of change and
so you can see it visually that looks
like right about there the slope of the
tangent line would be the same and so
this would be the C that exists now in
this video we're not trying to identify
the C's we're just trying to say can we
apply the mean value theorem so let's
look at this first interval from
negative 5 to negative 1 the closed
interval so we're going from negative 5
to negative 1
so are we differentiable over the
interval over the open interval well no
we have this this discontinuity over
here that's not going to make it
differentiable and of course this is
also if we're not continuous we're not
going to be differentiable here so this
discontinuity here actually violates
both of these conditions and so for this
first interval we would say no the mean
value theorem does not apply now the
second one from negative 1 to 3 so I'll
do this in a slightly different color so
we're going to go from negative 1 right
over there to 3 and if you look go over
this interval it looks like over that
interval over that closed interval our
function just really looks like a line
and so it is both continuous and
differentiable over that interval and it
makes sense that the mean value theorem
applies it's actually every C on this
interval is the derivative is the
instantaneous rate of change equal to
the average rate of change because it
looks linear over this interval so the
mean value theorem definitely applies
over there now what about from 3 to 7
the closed interval from 3 to 7 so when
you look at this closed interval
we're definitely continuous over the
interval so we meet the second criteria
but are we differentiable well a good
giveaway of a point that is continuous
but not differentiable is right over
here whenever you have these sharp edges
because what we don't have a
well-defined
slope of a tangent line here maybe you
know would it be would it be that would
it be that would it be that and so
because we aren't differentiable at that
point at X is equal to 6
we aren't differentiable over this open
interval from 3 to 7 and so the mean
value theorem does not apply and you can
even see that visually the average rate
of change between the endpoints of our
of our interval or if we want to think
about the slope of the secant line
that's that right over there and over
the interval we don't see any point
where the instantaneous rate of change
where the slope of the tangent line is
equal to the slope of the secant line
between the endpoints of our
interval so once again mean value
theorem would not apply now what about
from negative 3 to 2 I'll do this in
orange so from negative 3 right over
there to 2
well if we look at the open interval
from negative 3 to 2 so we're not
considered we're not considering what
happens at negative 3 and at 2 over the
open interval it does look like we are
both differentiable and continuous so
we're definitely differentiable over the
open interval but clearly we're not
continuous over the closed interval at
negative 3 we actually are not
continuous and so because of that the
mean value theorem does not apply and
you can actually even see that it would
not apply because if you're look at the
slope of the secant line between our
endpoints that's the secant line right
over there and so you can see over that
interval there is no C between negative
3 & 2 where the slope of the tangent
line or the instantaneous slope or the
derivative is going to be the same as
the slope of the secant line and that
doesn't violate the mean value theorem
because the mean value theorem just
doesn't apply here we haven't met the
condition of being continuous over the
closed interval